well in the United States it was
Mother's day yesterday and the failed
former and wannabe future president
Donald Trump issued a Mother's Day
greeting I guess with peace love and
attacks on women married to marxists or
something like that then degenerating
into an even more unhinged attack on
Caitlyn Collins and other people let's
take a very quick look at it this was
all on Trump's platform truth social
Trump not resp uh reactivating in any
serious way on Twitter but regularly
posting to truth starting with quote
happy Mother's Day to all in particular
the mothers Wives and Lovers of the
radical left fascists marxists and
Communists who are doing everything
within their power to destroy and
obliterate our once great Capital C
country please make these complete
Capital lunatics and capital M Maniacs
capital K Kinder capital G gentler
capital S softer and most importantly
yes capital S smarter so that we can
quickly make America great again
this is a really really sick Mother's
Day message
and a bizarre one he then turned his ire
from the lovers lovers of marxists to
Ron DeSantis posting quote Rob Des
sanctimonious and his poll numbers are
dropping like a rock
I would almost be inclined to say these
are record Falls the question is Rob
just young inexperienced or naive or
more troubling is he a fool who has no
idea what he is doing we already have
one of those in office we don't need
another one Maga so an attack on Rob Des
sanctimonious then going after Caitlyn
Collins who was the host of the Trump
CNN Town Hall that went so horribly
wrong last week posting quote it's
really amazing to watch the head of CNN
get absolutely lambasted for asking me
to do a so-called Town Hall in all
fairness nobody had any problems with
what he wanted to do until after the
show started that's a lie many people
had a problem with it when they quickly
realized that Ms Collins was not exactly
Barbara Walters or even close that's
when the trouble from the radical left
started neurotic little AOC with the bad
looking boyfriend went crazy he owns CNN
he's in their head they screamed CNN
take the great ratings you know I I have
to say one this is this is whacked
completely whacked out of his gourd but
one thing that does seem to be true
is that the Trump CNN Town Hall reminded
others like Fox News maybe there's a few
ratings points to be had with very
little effort in doing Trump stuff and
so until the Iowa rally was canceled
over the weekend Trump's Iowa rally was
canceled
Fox News planned to air it
even though for a while now they have
not aired Trump's rallies which is
interesting and clearly a reaction to
what they saw work relatively well for
CNN now one last note on this to be
thorough
the actual live ratings for the Trump
CNN Town Hall weren't that good they
were like in the 3 million range
the issue is it generated so much
discussion and the clips were shared and
it was discussed for days that CNN got a
lot of mileage out of it but the the
live event itself didn't actually do
that well from a ratings perspective
okay and then lastly as part of this
deranged rant from Trump on Truth quote
unless the Republicans get everything
they are asking for in terms of cost
cutting in particular all of the
trillions of dollars of inflation
causing waste that has stupidly been
approved over the last two years much of
it for the green New Deal con job they
will have no choice but to let the Biden
Administration default on U.S debt
better now than later especially with 32
trillion dollars of debt out there when
I was President the Dems would
cavalierly say they don't care about
default so so many lies here so many
lies first of all the deficit has
actually grown I'm sorry the debt has
grown more slowly under Biden than under
Trump so the idea of Biden is this out
of control spending guy that's a lie
secondly the green new deal is not law
and continuing to talk about all of the
spending on Green New Deal the green new
deal is not law the inflation reduction
act does contain certain things like
we're going to build electric vehicle
Chargers and things like that but there
is no green New Deal in the law right
now and lastly the idea of trump saying
let the U.S default on its debt it's
ridiculous it's not going to happen and
they love to pretend like it actually
might but I don't think even Trump
understands what would happen if that
were the case so A beautiful Mother's
Day on Troth Central for failed former
president Donald Trump one of our
sponsors is Helix sleep I have been
sleeping on a helix mattress at home for
years now I couldn't be more happy with
it I recommend it to everybody the other
day even though she's not allowed in the
big bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then Helix will match you with the
mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all Helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you were supporting
good jobs Helix sleep is giving my
audience up to 20 percent off plus two
free pillows what other mattress company
is going to give you 20 off go to
helixsleep.com Pacman the link is down
below